bonjour à tous merci de nous avoir
rejoindront fit l'écho dans ce numéro
nous allons en apprendre un peu plus sur
deux nouvelles figures du monde
économique et des yvelines nous irons à
la rencontre de daniel verlet
fraîchement élu à la tête de la chambre
de métiers et de l'artisanat et tout de
suite nous retrouvons gérard bacheliers
le nouveau président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
yvelines bonjour bonjour votre post est
en quelque sorte un peu nouveau ce qui
une réforme au sein des chambres de
commerce et d'industrie au prix nous en
dire un peu plus les huit départements
de l'île de france se sont réunis dans
une seule chambre régionale et en
particulier donc notre chambre
versailles yvelines val d'oise s'est
scindée en deux pour pouvoir se
regrouper dans une chambre régionale
donc où il y a maintenant oui chambres
départementales
donc voilà l'essentiel de la réforme qui
permet de mutualiser pas mal de moyens
au niveau international et pour le
besoin des entreprises
alors quel a été votre parcours pour
arriver jusqu à ce poste de président
alors auparavant bien sûr je suis chef
d'entreprise j'ai créé des entreprises
dans l'informatique en 84 et la dernière
en 2008
je suis à la chambre de commerce depuis
plus de dix ans et élu donc depuis 2004
la chambre de commerce de versailles
yvelines val d'oise donc je me suis
surtout intéressé à tout ce qui est lié
à l'appui aux entreprises donc à
l'entrepreneur à la création
d'entreprise au développement
d'entreprises à la transmission
d'entreprise et au financement
d'entreprises
ça a été essentiellement mes actions
depuis je suis élu à la chambre de
commerce la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie vous la connaissez pourtant
votre élection on a tout de même étonné
plus d'un puisque en général c'est les
présidents sortants qui ont été réélus
une élection a eu lieu le 15 novembre à
saint nombre d'élus de la chambre de
commerce de versailles souhaité que je
me présente et moi même j'ai pensé qu'il
était intéressant que je me présente à
cette candidature
donc je me suis présentée j'ai été élu
je voulais tout simplement défendre des
valeurs qui pouvait être un tout petit
peu différente de celle de mon
prédécesseur sans avoir d'animosité
particulière vis-à-vis de mon
prédécesseur bien sûr mais tous un plan
des valeurs un peu différente par
rapport au rôle que je voyais dans les
chambres de commerce peut-être un peu
plus de proximité vis-à-vis des
entreprises des du chef d'entreprise et
c'est pour ça que je me suis présenté
justement vous allez nous en dire un peu
plus également sur votre rôle
aujourd'hui en tant que président je
suis vice-président au niveau du bureau
régional mais j'ai un rôle
effectivement au niveau départemental
qui est un rôle de président délégué
puisque nous sommes une chambre de
commerce départementale donc nous
dépendons avant tout au niveau des
budgets l'organisation des chambres d'un
ensemble régional maintenant donc
l'intérêt c'est d'avoir une force une
force de mutualisation très importante
au niveau des yvelines il ya 46
entreprises qui sont en fait ne
ressortissants alors qu'un à 800 milles
sur l'ensemble de la région
en plus de cette mandature vous rester à
la tête de votre entreprise à au concept
à plaisir vous êtes un peu un homme sur
bouquet aujourd'hui il est vrai qu'il
n'était pas préparé véritablement à
cette prise de fonction à cette
présidence south bien longtemps j'ai
passe peu de temps actuellement dans mon
entreprise j'espère que bientôt je
pourrai revenir un peu plus dans les
activités de mon entreprise
bien que lorsqu'on est président d'une
chambre de commerce on se doit d'être
présent assez souvent et assez
fréquemment à la chambre et dans toutes
ses actions d'autant plus qu'à des
actions aussi régionale 2 les actions
départementales régionales
est-ce que vous avez un regard un peu
plus particulier sur l'agglomération de
saint quentin 8 saint quentin en
yvelines est pour nous une communauté
d'agglomération très très importante
bon moi même j'avais mon entreprise sur
saint quentin en yvelines elle était
située à montils 1 avant que je lavande
donc j'ai créé en 84 j ai vendu en 2004
à ericsson
donc pour moi saint quentin en yvelines
est un territoire très important et
c'est aussi un territoire très important
bien sûr pour la chambre de commerce des
yvelines et on a des actions au coma que
l'on développe au fil du temps et que je
crois qu'il ya vraiment une connexion
très importante
et que et on en est tout à fait
satisfait pour conclure on peut-être
revenir sur certains grands projets de
votre mandature
comme vous le savez le territoire des
yvelines est un territoire important
avec des filières très importante et en
particulier des filières industrielles
dans l'automobile est une filière est
essentielle pour ce territoire
donc on doit être dans le ses actions
avec nos partenaires que sont le conseil
général les communautés d'agglo qui
travaillent tous main dans la main pour
que effectivement cette filière puisse
se développer et aussi avoir sa mutation
vers une nouvelle mobilité donc la
chambre de commerce restent présentes
sur ces dossiers le grand paris express
est un dossier très important également
parce qu'on a besoin vraiment de
développer des communications
importantes entre saclay et saint
quentin en yvelines versailles est aussi
d'ailleurs
velizy puisque le développement de ce
cluster lienne paris saclay ne pourra se
faire que s'il ya des transports en
commun important et rapide
gérard machine et merci nous avoir aussi
merci dans les projets de la cci on a vu
l'importance du secteur automobile à ce
propos mercedes-benz avait installé son
nouveau siège social a menti ni la
première pierre vient d'être posée nous
y étions
truelle à la main till conrad le
président de mercedes france a posé
symboliquement la première pierre du
siège social de la marque
le 13 février c'est au pas du lac à
montigny le bretonneux que s'érigera
cette impressionnante structure de 19
mille mètres carrés en 2014
de quoi réconforter les acteurs locaux
sur l'attractivité du territoire
à l'heure où des villes perdent des
entreprises nous nous en gagnons ce qui
est quand même le signe de la grande
attractivité de notre agglomération et
de la ville de montigny-le-bretonneux
la deuxième chose aussi c'est le site du
renouveau de la zone d'activités du pas
du lac le siège social regroupera
désormais les trois entités existantes
le siège actuel d'euros concours sa
filiale financière de bail et son centre
de formation de la courneuve
en tout 700 salariés pas de création
d'emplois prévues pour l'instant mais
avec ses 80 mille véhicules vendus en
france en 2012
le leader du marché haut de gamme des
voitures individuelles espère bien se
développer davantage le pôle automobile
emploie déjà vingt mille salariés dans
les yvelines à la chambre de métiers
on comptabilise de 89,5 à 100% de
réussite dans les formations mécanique
et carrosserie
parmi eux quatre élèves de bac pro sont
employés par des concessions mercedes
nous voici maintenant au centre de
formation des apprentis de la chambre de
métiers et de l'artisanat et nous
retrouvons daniel varlet le nouveau
président de la chambre daniel varlet
bonjour bonjour
halloween est maintenant à la tête c'est
de la chambre de métiers de l'artisanat
depuis le 16 janvier mais cette
institution ne vous est pas inconnu oui
en effet j'ai déjà administrateur dans
une
votre mandature j'ai été aussi trésorier
de cette chambre de métiers et bien
l'attendre voilà président et
et à la tête de l'ensemble des services
de la chambre connaître l'institution ça
vous a aidé rue absolument puisque vous
savez il faut avoir quelques expériences
dans cette grande maison nous avons 140
salariés dans cette maison donc de faire
au service affaires à gérer et on doit
être au quotidien très proches de nos
artisans donc il faut avoir une grande
connaissance de la maison pour pouvoir
gérer au mieux cette institution alors
passé de trésorier à président qu'est ce
que ça change au final un trésorier
giresse et l'apprentissage de la maison
ça aide beaucoup pour savoir le
fonctionnement des services et j'irai
président c'est presque qui déclinent du
trésorier mais il faut avoir passé sur
des postes très importants comme ça pour
pouvoir bien connaître la chambre et la
plante présidente
c'est la continuité j'irai une passion
aussi d'un dévouement pour l'artisanat
justement vous êtes vous mêmes artisans
vous êtes artisan boucher à mareil marly
est ce que c'est un symbole fort oui je
suis dans le syndicalisme depuis
longtemps puisque nous avons des métiers
des bons laitiers et quelque part s'il
suffit pas de profiter du métier mais
faut aussi aider nos collègues il faut
savoir se défendre aussi la défense de
l'artisanat c'est une valeurs que j'ai
toujours défendues
ça me renforce dans mes convictions
votre prédécesseur monsieur prix migaud
a démissionné fin 2012
oui bien eu un laps de temps de 15 jours
sans président est-ce que tout est
revenu à la normale aujourd'hui oui bien
sûr
dès que la chambre n'est pas resté sans
direction puisque les services locaux à
boucher il ya eu un vice président de
ceux de voix qui appellent intendance
donc ça n'a rien du tout changé dans le
fonctionnement quelles sont les grandes
lignes de votre mandature les projets à
venir
le projet à venir c'est de changer ces
lieux dedans et ses lieux sur un nouveau
site à guyancourt
c'est un projet qui raoult en tête
depuis 2007 lourd projet puis sur les
dents des périodes difficiles des
cuisines dans les investissements et
autres et donc tarder à sortir mais
néanmoins je relance ce projet de
s'installer à guyancourt
et puis aussi le grande volonté de
montrer que l'ensemble des services que
la chandelle et qui offre aux artisans
et aussi des services pour notre
collectivité locale sur le côté
économique des choses sur les études
contrefaire la chambre de l'hôtel est un
partenaire on a des services tout à fait
compétent sur le positionnement des
artisans dans les villes dans les
centres villes dans les villages je
savais qu'on est quand même la plus
grande entreprise de france
on a 10% des gens qui représente
l'économie dans les rues au niveau
national au niveau national et c'est
vrai aussi dans les yvelines dispensant
de l'économie sont sont des artisans
donc c'est quand même une valeur très
très forte en ces périodes de récession
qu'on pourrait dire ou mauvaises et
collègue monsieur varlet merci beaucoup
de nous avoir réussi en faisant payer à
bientôt à la chambre des métiers des
idées ou passe maintenant à linge nda
pour ce numéro nous vous avons
sélectionné quelques rendez vous
programmé par la chambre des métiers et
la cci tout d'abord deux dates à retenir
à la chambre des métiers
une formation de deux jours pour booster
son marketing sur les réseaux sociaux
être plus visibles sur le web facebook
ou twitter ça se passe le 25 et 26
février
et puis une formation de trois jours
pour apprendre à créer son site web
les 11 12 et 18 mars avec l'utilisation
du logiciel word press
à noter tout de même il s'agit de
formations payantes est limité en nombre
de places la cci vous propose quant à
elle un rendez vous individuel et
gratuit avec un expert de l'institut
national de la propriété industrielle
le but vous apporter un premier niveau
d'information sur les brevets marques
droit d'auteur ou encore contrefaçon ça
se passe le 26 février et enfin pour
vous aider à lancer votre propre
entreprise
rendez vous
28 février de 14 à 17h30 pour une après
midi d'information
c'est la fin de ce programme merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve fois un
logo numéro le mi mars
ok